jason is with us jason's in tampa
florida hi jason how can we help
hey thanks for taking my call sure
what's up
um so i'm retired i've been retired for
about a year now i'm
40 years old i retired from the military
from the marine corps
and then from there i went on to be a
police officer for seven years
i was injured about two years ago and
i'm done now
i can't be a cop anymore do the couple
surgeries i've had
but again i don't really
need the money per se um that that i can
think of but my issue is i don't under
i don't know if i'm forgetting something
that is going to uh
set me back in life and i'm debating
right now should i go back to work
um i don't know if i should stay retired
or go back to work so
i'm 40. okay well what do you think
i've i've played it out in my head a
million different ways i have
my children's college taken care of i'm
putting more money
away than i'm spending uh i don't think
i need to
but i'm getting job offers you don't
need them you don't need to financially
correct yeah and you're getting job
offers that are what
i'm just getting job offers uh like for
example i live in a community where i'm
running like the fantasy football league
and
i'm meeting people and they're like hey
you should you should come work for me
for this or that and
so it's like tempting in my face all the
time um
and i don't know i okay i don't need a
lot of money
uh and like i'm i'm making enough of my
pensions now that i'm putting money
away so it's and i have a pretty nice
nest egg and my home is paid for
i don't i don't think you need to work
financially i'm convinced of that
listening to you
okay what was the nature of your
injuries
i i had a uh uh i tore my leg room in my
hip and it was pretty
so bad that they had to remove it so now
carrying all the gear around as a cop
and
running upstairs and stuff like that is
just uh no longer possible but i got
into a big fight
and pretty much just uh injured it after
uh after the arrest
yeah i understand okay wow well thank
you for your service by the way yeah
um thank you so what we find around here
is like i'll give you an example 20
years ago
um maybe more probably more than 20
years ago i was at a point where i
didn't have to work anymore financially
and so for the last 20 25 years or so
um i've done what i wanted to do because
i wanted to do it
and uh financially the only reason i do
it is to increase generosity
and um and you know i but it's not like
i
needed money but uh
the human i i think i'm just just you
know i'm
um i was your age when i was having this
discussion with myself oddly enough
because i'm
turning 60 this year so 20 years ago
and you're 40 right correct and so
um you know i just there's a
dignity and a fulfillment to doing
something that you care about
and you are a person of service you
served in the military
you served in the community as a
policeman uh
you know and you know uh
security you know uh how to handle
firearms
uh there's a lot of ways you could serve
at a very high
level that doesn't involve kicking down
doors
or running upstairs uh
you know i've got a good friend of mine
that was a um
uh he was in the seals and then he was
uh
he was in a police force after that on a
swat team
and uh today he's the director of
security for a huge company that i won't
name because everybody would know who he
is and everything else
and the only reason he does that and
then he does training and that's the
reason i've run into him because we're
handgun enthusiasts and so i've done
training with him tactical training with
him and so forth
but um but he just he's wired like you
are as a service i think you're going to
be unhappy if you're not serving
what do you think christy you know it's
interesting because even as he's talking
i'm just noticing you know
one of the questions i think we ask
ourselves through our entire life is
what do i need
to do next and jason you're at a spot
where you don't
need to do anything and so you're so
used to making decisions like we all are
and what do i
need to do for this goal or this
financial um goal or whatever that thing
is you don't need to do anything so you
have to ask yourself an
even harder question which is what do
you want to do
and sometimes that's a very difficult
question to answer sometimes
all the options can be paralyzing but
it's also a moment of opportunity jason
where
you don't have anything breathing down
your neck you don't have anything you
have to hold your feet to the fire
you're probably going to find something
you want to do like you said you're
doing
it because you want to but without that
pressure on your shoulders
you've got options it doesn't mean you
punch a clock 40 hours a week or you
work 80 hours a week
you can do whatever you want to do yeah
i tell our team around here if there's
ever something i quit having fun doing
i'll do it for a little while longer
while someone else picks it up but i'm
done yeah i don't have any desire i'm
not going to do a bunch of crap that i
don't want to do
yeah i don't need to it's not arrogance
it's just i don't
need to i want to so but i do get you
know tremendous i
i continue to do this show because it's
fun you know
the idea of serving and helping you
say it again during my dreams you're in
my dream job oh well
okay i spent a lot of time with my my
friends and
whenever we talk about finances i end up
talking
you know teaching them instead of
actually having somebody i can bounce
ideas off of
because they all want to be where i'm at
but they're still like 10 15 years away
so it's just one of those situations
where i really never have anybody given
me advice and so i end up watching your
show and
my own research and that type of stuff
and i'm really
orientated so when i don't have a goal
because i've hit them all for the most
part
you hit your financial goals and so you
need different goals
and i'm worried about going back to work
because mostly been in service type jobs
so now
as i can't do that anymore i mean i knew
i know i have the expertise and sales
and stuff but you have the expertise and
you have the expertise
in military and in law enforcement
and you can use your brain and your
teaching skills
in that area easily you're you're going
to go do something you're not going to
sit on your butt and go fishing
for 40 more years you're 40 years old
you're not going to fish for 40 years
until you're 80. you're not going to go
bowling
for 40 years god shoot me uh or
something i don't know whatever the
thing is
right golf whatever it is you're not
you're not going to do that
there's not there's happiness and
dignity in serving
yeah and so find a way to do that and
find a way to monetize it because it's a
good way to keep score
if what you're doing is effective or not
i like the competition in the
marketplace and there's the dignity that
comes with that
with the paycheck with the income that
you get from that jason i would
encourage you
to not not only the past experience and
expertise you have from what you have
done in law enforcement in the
military but even that thing you just
said and you said it kind of like you're
joking like ha ha you have my dream job
no what what are you saying with that
nervous laughter is there something
where you want to help people with their
finances or do coaching or do
consulting or help people get to where
you are there's so many options for you
of what you can do now
but i would i would lean in i tell
people all the time especially through
business boutique
lean into the things that make you light
up if there's something that lights you
up right now even if it's different from
what you have been doing
lean into that don't shy away from it
you've got you've got an opportunity
to do those and it's that it's that
tough question what do you want what do
you want to do
it's a fun time to ask it yeah but in
terms of do i need to work no you don't
need to work financially right
emotionally and spiritually you do need
to work
yeah it's good for you yeah and uh
there's times that i you know i'm doing
something because i'm just
refuse i just don't want to lose yeah i
can't stand losing
yeah and so i work like a maniac just to
win
yeah it has nothing to do with the money
yeah i just can't stand loose
i can't stand to launch a book one of
you guys with your personalities and it
not being number one drive me nuts and
so i'm all over it i'm
down in there with you all fighting and
looking at the details and getting it
out of here or looking at
one of our live events or going through
all this covered crap and i it really
wasn't about
the company was going to be in financial
trouble or something here
uh i mean there's about 10 minutes there
we worried about that when everybody was
worried about everything
but the thing was it's just now okay how
how can i get through this and not lose
yeah how can we set a standard that's
different how could the way we reacted
to this
from a leadership standpoint how can we
do that and so there's just there's a
there's something like that that lights
you up and there's a lot of different
ways that can manifest itself for you
dude
so you're gonna be doing something uh
but choose it
and then go win because it's actually
what you've done
twice now in your career